all right so
[Applause]
first off we have to start with the
obvious one
gay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he didn't even flinch
[Music]
nothing
how you doing people it's june 7 2022
this is the reuben report i'm dave rubin
we are live streaming on rumble blaze tv
and youtube as long as they'll allow us
don't forget to uh subscribe tap that
notification bell etc etc if you have
not seen it yet uh that was a little
clip of part one of my interview
with florida governor ron desantis which
is up right now on youtube and rumble
the full thing is already up uh totally
ad free at ruben
report.locals.com and i wanted to shift
a little bit today because you know we
were doing yesterday's show coming off
uh this awesome event in orlando with
the governor and you know a month and a
half of touring and being out on the
road and yesterday we're doing a bunch
about politics and you know just all the
bad polling right it's a lot of bad
polling everyone gets it the
democrats are not doing a good job this
joe biden guy is an incompetent buffoon
the economy's not doing well we got
inflation it's hard to get stuff we got
this weird war we got all sorts of
problems okay everybody gets it and i
finished up the show yesterday i was
like
i don't think that's what i want to do
today i want to do something a little
bit different today and then there was
this incredible clip on msnbc so so that
directly hit the heart of what i'm
constantly trying to wake you guys up to
which is that the media really is the
problem more than anything else their
endless bs is the problem so it's not
just that we have to focus on okay there
are bad things happening right like
there are bad economic indicators we
realize things aren't going that well
it's that we have to be able to see
through the fog
of nonsense and the more that you see
through the fog of nonsense you the more
you realize that what they're really
trying to do as you see it is keep you
either very very fearful constantly
afraid right the winter of death is
coming and all of those kind of things
or they want to just censor you to the
point that you won't know what reality
is
so that's what this show is going to be
about it's going to be about their
endless ramping up of censorship and the
way they're trying to trick you into
thinking that the bad guys are the good
guys and the good guys are the bad guys
but speaking of good guys uh because the
tour went so well i announced yesterday
that we are adding one more stop
in my hometown my new hometown of miami
i will be at the miami improv look at
those glasses people
on july 14th at 8pm you can get tickets
at
slash daverubin.com there will be at
least one special guest
from the great city of miami in the
great state of florida and also we got a
whole bunch of new mugs and t-shirts and
all kinds of stuff
like this mug right here over at
daverubin.store okay let's go right into
it so this was the clip that i saw
yesterday going viral that sparked my
whole idea for today's show this is this
guy dan pfeiffer who's a podcast guy i
think he worked in the obama
administration
he's got a book it's going to be pushed
all over left-wing media and he's on
this uh joe scarborough show on the
mental institution known as msnbc
and the scarborough guy he's bananas
he's not totally bananas like joy reid
like not like let's institutionalize the
guy bananas but he's not good at what he
does and he's a misinformation
specialist and all those things anyway
this guy dan pfeiffer
is on there and pfeiffer's freaking out
because you people are watching ben
shapiro and dan bongino to deliberately
spread lies uh channel them through
russia or deliberately spread health
care lies i don't i think the government
would pull their fec license why can't
we pass basic regulations to make these
companies be more transparent about the
algorithms that spread the lies on
everything from covid to january the
sixth we absolutely should be able to
pass we actually have to pass them i
think these social media companies are
in many ways the tobacco companies of
this era they're exploiting loopholes in
the law to deeply damage america it's
just connected to your cancer metaphor
and with little to no regulation you go
to facebook on a daily basis the most
the posts with the most engagement are
from dan shapiro or ben shapiro dan
bongino candice owens it is right-wing
content it dwarfs progressive content it
dwarfs mainstream media content which is
actually should be the part that scares
us the most that ben shapiro's daily
wire has more followers and engagement
many times more than the new york times
or cnn that is a pro
ben shapiro he's a very very scary dude
as i was off as i would often say during
the uh during the tour it's like people
are afraid of ben shapiro can you
imagine being afraid of bench beer like
you're going to see ben shapiro in a
dark alley oh my god it's bench what's
he going to do grab the
like fire it at you like a chinese star
i mean come on people what are we really
afraid of benchmare he talks fast it's
going to be okay anyway with these
freaks these these are the
misinformation specialists you've got
corporate
msnbc press that lies and lies and lies
and lies about brett kavanaugh and lies
about russia collusion and lies about
everything from kyle rittenhouse and
jesse smilet the whole freaking thing
right they lie about everything but
they're very concerned that you guys
aren't buying their lies anymore and
then what's happening you guys go on to
your computer machines with the typing
and the keyboards and everything and you
start communicating with each other and
sharing articles with each other that
often debunk the lies that they're
spreading and who are people that are
doing such things well you've got ben
shapiro over at the daily wire doing
such things you've got dan bongino with
the bongino report doing such things
you've got candace owens and she could
be the scariest because the woman is a
black conservative and oh my god that's
a narrative buster for these freaks so
they are seriously worried and then of
course what do they call for
because people are not paying attention
to them and they are paying attention to
shows like this and shows of some of
those people who i just mentioned who
i'm very proud to call friends what do
they want they want regulation
ah because if only the government could
step in and reorder things walk in a
government regulator you know with the
plastic hat could walk into facebook and
say uh mr zuckerberg uh we want to see
your algorithm and uh we'd like to
rewrite your algorithm
so that more progressive news is seen on
your system there
and of course this is ridiculous the
government doesn't hire the best of the
best they i they usually hire the worst
of the worst uh and also it is not the
right of the government to be walking
into private companies and all those
things and we can talk about some
ancillary ways that big tech could be
broke up broken up you know my feelings
about competition which is why i started
locals and maybe they could break up
some of these companies but regulation
is just ridiculous but what this really
is all about it's not about the minutia
of regulation or breaking up companies
or antitrust or any of that this is
these people are freaking out because
they have lied about covid uh contrary
to what uh scarborough or his sidekick
said they have lied about january 6th
they have lied about everything and you
guys get it you guys see it and now they
are freaking out so please government do
something
but what else
happens on facebook well pfeiffer
continued you're saying that like the
republican agenda is backed up by the
freaks on facebook and so they don't
want to do anything about it absolutely
it is just making sure yes be very clear
is that facebook is the most powerful
messaging platform for the extreme maga
message that benefits the republicans
they have very little they like to cry
about facebook and big tech and then
they just laugh their way to the bank
when facebook pushes their message
including the big lie all across into
people's rooms all across this country
let's talk about that extreme
mega message or as the kids on the
internet are calling it ultra mega what
is the extreme maga message now i've
been around these these trump people
i've uh just a few weeks ago i was at
mar-a-lago and there were scary people
there like larry elder and dinesh
d'souza and dan bongino and some of the
people that they're freaking out about
right now and i met a whole bunch of
people that really like america they
believe in capitalism they believe in
individual rights they like the
constitution things like that now you
may not agree with some of those things
but this is the new framing the new
framing is this is this is
it's not just maga anymore these are
extreme ultra mega people with lasers
coming out of their eyes they're
freaking everybody out so again what is
the answer well the government better do
something about it uh we got some info
here this is a tweet from facebook top
ten and here are the top ten uh
performing
uh pages on facebook in the last 24
hours you got franklin graham at number
one pure wow entertainment i've never
heard of that people royals i don't know
what that is then you've got ben shapiro
then you've got
fox news then you've got marie claire
good for them still at it uh then you've
got fox news again then you've got town
and country then you've got ben shapiro
and then you've got town and country so
yes it is a lot of ben shapiro and it is
a lot of fake uh
fake news uh it is a lot of fox news uh
that is what it is people are clicking
these things now is it possible there's
algorithmic algorithmic manipulation
of course i talk about it all the time
is it possible that daily wire is
pumping a ton of money into advertising
of course they are right is it possible
that fox is doing that is it possible
that people on the right are more
engaged right now because they feel that
the left is destroying the country so
they're the ones that are clicking
things right now and push it pushing
messaging out there of course is it also
if you remember do you remember when
obama was running for president uh all
that 10 years ago and remember where the
whole thing the entire media was like oh
you see how barack obama because he's
using young people and young people are
on facebook and they're sharing articles
and it's so wonderful so when it's their
guys who are winning they love social
media they love facebook they love big
tech
but when you know we start winning when
people stop buying their bs then they
are freaking out so anyway good for ben
shapiro hitting like three of those top
10
links on facebook man that is some ben
shapiro thug life right there
[Music]
we threw that in right before the show
thought you'd like that one uh so what
is the position
of the left on social media censorship
uh because they're freaking out they're
losing the narrative and when you're
losing the narrative you better put down
your foot on the people and silence the
people and censor the people and all
that good stuff so that is where we are
going to shift right now but uh real
quick i want to talk to you guys about
raycon you know lately i've been
listening to a lot of fleetwood mac and
jordan peterson that's true
and it's been great one reason i enjoy
listening it's because i use my raycon
wireless earbuds to do it raycon's
everyday earbuds look feel and sound
better than ever with optimized gel tips
for the perfect in-ear fit these earbuds
are super comfortable and they will not
budge trust me raycon's offer three
sound profiles to match what you're
listening to plus noise isolation and
awareness mode so you can choose to be
immersed in sound or be able to hear
your surroundings when you need to like
if you're walking your dog and there's a
crazy driver i absolutely love using my
raycons when i'm taking my dog clyde on
walks in the iguana infested
neighborhoods of miami raycons give you
eight hours of playtime and a 32-hour
battery life then when you need to
charge it's super easy you can even do
it wirelessly and here's a huge selling
point with raycons you get the same
quality audio as other premium audio
brands but at half the price yes really
but that doesn't mean they won't last
i've seen people talking about their
raycons falling three stories getting
lost in rain and snowstorms and still
working afterwards it's no wonder
raycon's everyday earbuds have almost
fifty thousand five star reviews check
out raycon's wireless earbuds my guess
is you're gonna wanna leave them a five
star review yourself go to buy raycon
dot com ruben today to get 15 percent
off your order that's by raycon dot com
slash reuben to score 15
off
and now back to me all right so what is
the democrat position on all this
because even though
they are the ones that have lied and
lied and lied they had lied about kovid
they lied about russia collusion they
lied about brett kavanaugh they lied
about jesse smilet you guys know all of
this stuff they lie about everything no
one ever gets called out well we call
them out let's say on this crazy right
wing media but in within their own
system it's a constant protection racket
you lie other people lie for you you
just work around it everybody's in on
the lie so nobody calls anybody out no
one ever gets fired nobody ever gets
booted okay fine
so what is their position as a lot of
people are clicking ben shapiro videos
on facebook as fox continues to crush it
in the ratings
as this show outperforms pretty much all
of the cable news shows on msnbc and cnn
well their position
is we need to do something related to
censorship and regulation of course here
is uh mental [ __ ] aoc
i mean
and who's managing who's in charge of
all these platforms
that are perpetuating this
misinformation and violence
men
mark zuckerberg
where you at bro
where you at
4chan
read it
what's up
because all these little things that
they're talking about when they say free
speech they don't actually mean it
because they don't they don't protect
all speech
they drool do draw a line at some point
but you know people like mark zuckerberg
are busy having dinner with tucker
carlson who's also airing little great
replacement theories that are inciting
violence
i really don't think aoc is a real human
being and what i mean by that is not
that she's a cylon
but that she is a construct that that
what you're seeing there is not a real
person who believes anything that she's
saying she is an actress she is a
trained actress who does these little
videos where are you at mark zuckerberg
where are you at who do we have to blame
for this we have to blame men
they're not
everything she says is complete nonsense
and a lie and everything else oh mark
zuckerberg's having dinner with tucker
carlson so because they're having dinner
then obviously she they're in the
cahoots with each other and it's like
man
man you are not a real person aoc she is
an
abject clown she is an abject clown so
why is she so afraid why is she so
afraid of tucker carlson having a show
that people watch and tucker carlson
doesn't do replacement theory stuff it's
the left you know this i didn't even
talk about this for the few weeks that
everyone was freaking out about
replacement theory which is not even a
phrase i've ever said on this show once
uh but it's the left that is obsessed
with replacement theory
people have pointed out that over the
last couple years they're constantly
articles in the new york times about how
the demographics in the united states
are changing and it's browning and that
that is good for democrats and that that
in essence is the replacement theory but
then when tucker carlson says that there
are demographic issues in the united
states which there obviously are there
obviously are demographic issues we can
talk about all the all the reasons uh
that people of specific ethnicities and
colors and all these things might vote
one way or another and you know if it
wasn't for the democrats constantly
screaming racism i think an awful lot of
people would not be voting for them in
the first place uh but they lie about
everything and uh it's not just aoc
who's now freaking out because men
it's those evil men
who i didn't know she was a biologist
did you know that aoc is a freaking
biologist i had no idea that she knows
that mark zuckerberg is a man i have no
idea does it mark zuckerberg though if
you if you took the clothes off him you
feel like he has no there's no genitals
down there like it would be like a ken
situation like he's like some sort of
humanoid robot kind of thing anyway uh
aoc not a good lady and here's a guy
that i voted for and i completely regret
voting for it this is former president
barack obama it was going to be hope and
change and uh no he didn't get it
exactly how he wanted it right he had
two terms and obviously he didn't fix
anything right because then
four years later we got
joe biden to fix all the stuff that
obama obviously never fixed
but obama he's really big on censorship
and freaking you out that misinformation
is going to kill people what does still
nag at me though
was my failure to fully appreciate at
the time
just how susceptible we had become
to lies
and conspiracy theories
despite having spent years being a
target of disinformation myself in some
cases industry standards may replace or
substitute for regulation but
regulation has to be part of the answer
beyond that
tech companies need to be more
transparent about how they operate
around one in five americans is still
willing to put themselves at risk and
put their families at risk
rather than get vaccinated
people are dying
because of misinformation
i regret voting for him i really regret
voting for him
barack if you're watching this i don't
like you and you you have ripped the
mask off and shown what you really are
now first off on that thing at the end
one in five people haven't been boxed
and the implication is they're killing
people and why are they not facts
because of misinformation now i'm not
back i didn't kill anybody pretty sure
the guys in this room are in fact can i
say that
nice
you guys are in a lot of trouble with
your respective health insurance
companies um
and i wouldn't have forced them to get
back that's the point okay uh but you
see what he did there if you didn't get
vaxxed you were bad you were killing
people and you were and it was because
you were subjected to misinformation i
know an awful lot of people right now
that regret getting the vax or regret
getting boosted i don't know anyone that
feels the other way that didn't get
vaccines like boy i sure do wish i got
it you know plenty of people got coveted
got natural immunity and everything else
but let's not even make this about covid
what he's really again going to is if we
just had more control
he says you know they said bad things
about me i was the i was the subject of
misinformation i mean think how pompous
and smug that is that barack obama the
media literally gave him a hand job for
eight years of his presidency they
refused to write anything negative about
him literally that was an odd use of
literally but they probably did in a
literal sense somebody did feel like
somebody at politico gave him a hand job
dubin definitely thank you toobin
definitely gave him a handy the point is
that
that he but i you know
i was the subject of misinformation so
what do we need to do again it's
regulate we have to use our power
because too many of you people and what
he means by you people in essence is you
right-wing racist bigots
you guys are talking too much and
sharing too much so we better freaking
regulate we better use the power of the
state to make sure that you can't get
information uh well here's his uh his
buddy joe biden who was the vp when he
was in charge and joe biden's the
president now and uh he also is a big
fan of censorship because sometimes
people don't listen to a joke
unfortunately while our military's
stepping up as they always do
there are others sitting on the
sidelines
and we're standing in the way
if you haven't gotten vaccinated do it
personal choice
impacts us all
our hospitals our countries
i make a special appeal to social media
companies and media outlets please deal
with the misinformation and
disinformation that's on your shows
it has to stop
covet 19 is one of the most formidable
enemies america has ever faced
we've got to work together not against
each other look the unvaccinated are
responsible for their own choices
but those choices have been fueled by
dangerous misinformation on cable tv and
social media
you know these companies and
personalities are making money
by peddling lies and allowing
misinformation that can kill their own
customers and their own supporters
it's wrong
it's immoral
i call on the purveyors of these lies
and misinformation to stop it
stop it now
oh screw you you old windbag if you want
to talk about misinformation joe or
joe's teleprompter writer how about joe
biden remember last june joe biden if
you get the covid vaccine you won't get
or transmit kovid remember that one was
that misinformation or disinformation or
a big lie or an old buffoon who doesn't
know what he's saying which one was that
and should have should facebook have
censored that man you guys get it you
know what the problem is my audience is
too smart so a lot of times i'm saying
things to them and i know they get it
already uh
they're just absolutely awful also
he says that he wants the social media
companies to uh control information on
their shows
because he doesn't know what decade
we're in uh so that's an issue also uh
and this constant this constant preening
about the unvacs that the unvacs were
going to overwhelm the hospitals and all
that that was the misinformation that
was the lie can i get video connor
you're on the video you you do the video
around here can i get all the video that
they must be hiding from all the
hospitals that collapsed during this
there must have been a hospital
somewhere in africa or somewhere where
there isn't clean water or something
where there were hospitals just going
down right didn't happen anywhere even
in even in detroit
didn't even we're looking for okay we're
going to keep looking because somehow
not we didn't see one video of just
bodies everywhere or a country or a city
that collapsed under covid the winter of
death remember the winter of death yeah
that was a good one that was
misinformation they lie lie lie and lie
you get it okay so what else are they
gonna do beyond push
for censorship what else it's this push
for censorship and it's a and it's a
correlation
it's a connection between democrat
activists and what what people in power
they can kind of do together what it is
that these people can do together so
let's go full circle here let's go back
to this dan pfeiffer fella on the mental
institution known as msnbc
well they just lie what can we do
well i think
the problem around this is getting worse
every single day the immediate the right
wing media advantage this this this
information propaganda operation is so
much more powerful now than when i
worked in the world it's getting bigger
it's getting bigger flourishing yes and
metastasizing metastasizing cancer that
is a perfect metaphor for what we are
dealing with and it is i think what we
have to do is
radically rethink how we communicate
everyone has a role to play here the
media i think a lot of people may have
to rethink how they deal with people who
lie for a living and then the social
media companies haven't have an
obligation to do more we can't rely on
them to do it on their own and so this
is where congress and regulars have to
step in to think about how we regulate
these algorithms that are pushing this
disinformation for profit
through confession that's what my friend
viva fryo he says about these people
everything that they say we're doing
is what they're doing and what's
interesting is
let's say i believe all of left wing
media is lying which i do and let's say
they believe all of right-wing media is
lying and let's say that's actually what
they believe i'm not calling to censor
them they're calling to censor us that's
the fundamental difference between
basically being somewhat on the right
and somewhat being on the left i believe
in freedom and choice and competition
and that you can have some capacity over
your own mind and pick the things to
watch and we should have a marketplace
of ideas and a marketplace of
competition what they say is if you
don't believe what we believe we must
destroy you those are fundamentally
different ideas that you really have to
understand i also love how they really
seem to share a brain these people even
the way they talk to each other he's
like there's misinformation out there
and she's like there's misinformation
out there there's it's metastatizing
it's metastasizing it's like there
really are just like a board like
there's one idea just passing through
their very very vapid brains but really
what he wants and again this is an
assistant and a former assistant to
barack obama he wants the government to
penalize you but it's not just him
there's this woman that no one elected
up in new york who is the governor of
new york
i call her kathy c word you know what
the c word is i don't like this woman
again she was not voted for by anybody
right she's the one who was appointed
after they got rid of andrew cuomo and i
did not know because it happened last
august that andrew cuomo had stepped
down but when as you may remember
adam carolla
brought me back on the grid and he said
andrew cuomo stepped down and i said
before you tell me who replaced him i
guarantee you it's going to be worse and
i think i've
turned out to be right on that one well
what's she going to do up in new york
they're going to be watching you people
because you have computers in the
internet
and in the state of new york
we're now requiring social media
networks to monitor and report
hateful conduct on their platform
and now we're gonna
continue focusing on this we're going to
establish a task force on social media
and violent extremism to investigate the
role of social media in promoting
domestic terror and our great leader our
attorney general will be championing
this cause with every power her office
can bring it at their disposal thank you
senator d'bailey jamal bailey and
senator assembly member desmond meeks
thank you
task force they've got a task force to
watch out for hateful content online
well i'm online right now i don't like
you kathy i think you're a really really
bad person i think you're abusing your
power i also think you've gone a little
crazy with the botox and the eyebrows
are getting a little too high you're
doing a little pelosi thing i mean at
some point lady let's lower the eyebrows
it's starting to look bananas okay
but are you going to report me i just
said something mean about you now i'm
not for anyone harming you i'm not for
anything illegal being done but i am
allowed to call out your [ __ ] we've
got something here called the first
amendment and the first amendment you're
allowed to say mean things about people
and you're allowed to call out the
hypocrites and the buffoons and that's
exactly what you are
lady but again this is what's just going
to happen and in some ways this is good
in some ways this is good the further
breaking up of the red and blue states
is somewhat good because that's what
federalism is all about you will live in
dystopian places where they will control
and monitor what you say if you live in
new york and california
or perhaps you could live in free places
like florida and texas
where
they will actually look into what's
going on at these companies see if we're
being manipulated and push
for more free speech right figure out
what's going on people want honesty in
the game right the problem is we're all
playing a rigged game we know it's
rigged and we keep playing but what does
the administration's
the administration want to do uh when
it's related to all of this i think you
know you may remember jen sake she was
the former white house press secretary
she's been replaced by a black lesbian
and she was freaking out not too long
ago about elon musk buying twitter
because elon said hey i'm going to
thinking about buying the twitter and
i'm going to kind of open it up and make
sure that nobody's being silenced and
that's very scary to these people
okay
there's nothing happening in the world
today here uh what i can tell you is a
general matter no matter who owns or
runs uh twitter uh the president has
long been concerned about the power of
large social media platforms uh what
they have that power they have over our
everyday lives has long argued that tech
platforms must be held accountable for
the harms they cause
ah so tech platforms must be held
accountable for the harm that they cause
i wonder if her misinformation
should should she be held accountable
for the harm that that causes for the
lies that she spewed every single day
and what of course is also interesting
is that all elon musk said was hey i'm
going to just look into this and try to
make the playing field more even but
that really freaked these people out now
why would it freak these people out
because they know they've had it good
because the tech companies
contrary to everything you're seeing on
msnbc and from sake and everyone else
the tech companies have been working
with the democrats very obviously very
very obviously remember the hunter biden
laptop
why did they cover that up before the
election who did that help did it help
democrats or republicans
remember kicking donald trump remember
that orange guy you remember him right
he was the president of the united
states in case he forgot and all the
tech companies kicked him off all at the
same time do you think there was some
collusion there and do you think that
helped republicans or democrats oh and
you remember this one from jan saki
about how the white house actually does
do a little something on the dl related
to social media in terms of actions alex
that
we have taken or we're working to take i
should say from the federal government
uh we've increased uh disinformation
research and tracking within the surgeon
general's office we're flagging
problematic posts for facebook that
spread this information we're working
with doctors and medical professionals
to connect uh two connected medical
experts with popular with popular who
are popular with their audiences with uh
with accurate information and boost
trusted content so we're helping get
trusted content out there we also
created the covid19 the covid community
core to get factual information into the
hands of local messengers and we're also
investing as you'll have seen in the
presidents the vice presidents and dr
fauci's time
what basically she said there is we have
to be in charge of the information and
if people start saying some other things
we're gonna have to suppress it uh the
key line there of course we covered it
many times at the at the time it was
happening was we flag things for social
media companies that is as close to a
violation of the first amendment as you
can get the idea that the government
calls up someone at facebook or twitter
and says you better do something about
this right like that's as close to the
line as you can get right it's not the
government necessarily stopping the
company from saying something or
stopping that account from posting
something but perhaps it is but the
pressure right the pressure alone could
be enough hey we're going to take away
some of your benefits or we're going to
look into your books a little bit more
or you don't want to upset the president
you know that's as close and that's what
they did and they said it right there
and there was no investigation into that
you know who did they contact at social
media companies who who at the
administration contacted someone at a
social media company what did they tell
them to suppress why did they tell them
to suppress it did it turn out to be
untrue etc etc
but what's really going on here
to wrap this thing up really nicely why
are they trying to suppress information
why are they trying to make you think
that all of us are bigots and racists
why do they want you to think we're all
mean scary people well it's all a giant
distraction
you know it i know it they know it they
know that we know it and they keep doing
it uh here is nbc's yamiche alcindor
saying that the democrats do have to
shift away have to shift the narrative
because uh they're doing a pretty pretty
shitty job about everything there are so
many things that people are juggling
between gas prices and inflation baby
formula abortion
and the shootings that are happening
these lawmakers are going to try to now
have a narrative to focus the country's
attention to say look at this thing do
not turn away and understand that while
all those other things are really really
important the foundation of our country
what makes our country function is a
democracy that we have to protect and
they're gonna have to do that in the
face of republicans who are lying still
about the 2020 election and who are
getting elected and installing people
who have um the really motivations that
were that were what happened and why
people broke into the capital in the
first place
okay so what's interesting about that
again i know the people that broke into
the capital we better focus on that and
okay blah blah blah but she sort of
acknowledges that the democrats are not
doing well and we all know it and again
you don't need me to read you the polls
on these things just check the price of
gas and everything else but it's not
just that the democrats are doing are
not doing well it's that nobody is
tuning into these ridiculous shows
anymore and that's why they constantly
have to ramp up the hysteria the ratings
are absolutely abysmal we've got some
info from fox news despite a busy news
month during may that included tragic
mass shootings and major political
primaries msnbc was outdrawn during may
by such networks as fx bravo paramount
tv land
espn2 freeform lifetime and hallmark
among the prime time demo
now i haven't had cable in a while but
you know golden girls used to be on tv
land it used to be on hallmark and it
used to be on lifetime i don't know if
it's still on any of those channels but
this if this is all just that the golden
girls is crushing msnbc then i'm gonna
pop open a bottle of champagne at the
end of today because obviously you could
learn far more from four retired women
trying to live a good life uh in miami
in the mid 80s into the early 90s than
you could from anything on msnbc but do
you see the point so what's happening is
people are tuning out of that crap
despite all of the craziness right we
have all this craziness related to
abortion and roe v wade the shootings
all of the stuff that's going on with
the economy
and people are just tuning out of their
nonsense so to really bring you home
here because i like to kind of give you
something to walk away with how do we
push back well we get good people
involved and one of those people
of course is elon musk and now there's
something interesting going on with this
twitter thing right now because one of
the things that's happening is that uh
you know twitter because once you say
hey i'm gonna buy
your company and then the company has to
open up the book so that you know the
guy buying it knows that he's actually
buying what has been promised what's
happening now is as they've started to
open up the books some weird stuff is
going on it's like oh how many bots are
there how many of these accounts are
fake we thought maybe it was five
percent it's looking like it could be 20
if not more he's finding out all sorts
of stuff so now the deal is looking a
little bit shaky but we have a little
info here from the daily wire which is
ben shapiro's website and ben shapiro is
a very can we get that image up one more
time before we throw to this text here
ben shapiro is a very
very scary guy
[Music]
all right here's ben shapiro's daily
wire and what's going on with elon and
the twitter machine
in late april twitter and musk agreed to
a deal worth 44 billion but musk had
previously requested info on fake
accounts before his purchase of twitter
could officially go through he has
claimed that spam accounts could have a
massive impact on what twitter is
actually worth on monday the spacex
founder took his demands a step further
by sending twitter a detailed letter
through his attorney as twitter's
prospective owner mr musk is clearly
entitled to the requested data to enable
him to prepare for transitioning
twitter's business to his ownership and
to facilitate his transaction financing
musk's attorney mike ringler wrote a
letter filed with the sec at this point
mr musk believes twitter is
transparently refusing to comply with
its obligations under the merger
agreement which is causing further
suspicion that the company is
withholding the requested data due to
concern for what mr musk's own analysis
of the data will uncover
based on twitter's behavior to date and
the company's latest correspondence in
particular mr musk believes the company
is actively resisting and thwarting his
information rights and the company's
corresponding obligations under the
merger agreement wrangler remark this is
a clear material breach of twitter's
obligations under the merger agreement
and mr musk reserves all rights
resulting there from including his right
not to consummate the transaction and
his right to terminate the merger
agreement so this is really fascinating
stuff and you know when i talk about
twitter i get it a lot of you are not on
twitter because you're wise people when
i went to the locals
breakfast in orlando a lot of you say
that now locals is your only social
media which is fantastic but the truth
is whether you're on it or not it does
exist it has a certain amount of
influence in all of those things so musk
says he's going to buy it and now he's
under uncovering that it's been a huge
amount of [ __ ] right so it's not
just that they censor certain people and
we know they're always censoring people
on the right nobody on the left is being
censored on uh on twitter okay and the
hunter biden laptop and kicking donald
trump off and shadow banning and all of
those things but now that the accounts
themselves are fake and what in what
ways could twitter or whoever's really
controlling twitter in what ways could
they have really changed our political
dialogue if they could have sent all
sorts of bots to hate certain people and
not hate other people or promote certain
people and not promote other things or
that the new york times has you know
something like 50 million followers but
rarely gets 10 retweets right i mean all
of the [ __ ] is being exposed and
maybe what elon musk really was planning
to do here and man would that be a tip
of the cap to elon musk maybe he was
really never planning to buy the thing
and his plan was hey i'm going to offer
this crazy amount of money so that
they'll have to say yes but i know that
the whole thing's [ __ ] right because
he's got insiders he knows what's going
on and i'm going to expose that it was
all nonsense and then i will let it
collapse under the weight of its own
crap and then the shareholders will
probably all sue the board and sue all
of the executives into oblivion because
they were running a giant shell game so
this is sort of like an enron or a ponzi
scheme type situation
so all the guy wanted
in essence was this thing to be more
pro-free speech or at least to expose
the nonsense and the entire machine is
freaking out on top of the fact that
then for weeks we've seen articles about
how he's really racist and he grew up in
south africa so he's obviously racist
and everything else so what do you do
you fight back that's elon
elon's way of fighting back but there's
other things that you can do there are
legal measures and sometimes you do have
to use the power of government to fight
for the right things this is why i don't
consider myself a pure libertarian as
much as i like libertarian ideas i do
believe that there is some role for
government and one of the ways that you
can use government effectively is use it
in small ways to do good things much
like that guy ron desantis is doing
right here in florida and we've got some
info on that from flggov.com
governor ron desantis signed senate bill
7072 to hold big tech accountable by
driving transparency and safeguarding
floridian's ability to access and
participate in online platforms this
session we took action to ensure that we
the people
real floridians across the sunshine
state are guaranteed protection against
the silicon valley elites said governor
ron desantis many in our state have
experienced censorship and other
tyrannical behavior first hand in cuba
and venezuela if big tech sensors
enforce rules inconsistently to
discriminate in favor of the dominant
silicon valley ideology they will now be
held accountable what we've seen
what we've been seeing across the u.s is
an effort to silence intimidate and wipe
out dissenting voices by leftist media
and big corporations today by signing sb
7072 into law florida is taking back the
virtual public square as a place where
information and ideas can flow freely
many of our constituents know the
dangers of being silenced or have
silence or have been silenced themselves
under communist rule thankfully in
florida we have a governor that fights
against big tech oligarchs that contrive
manipulate and censor if you voice views
that run contrary to their radical
leftist narrative that is lieutenant
governor
jeannette nunez uh finishing that up so
do you see the again the fundamental
difference what did did this dan
pfeiffer clown say what did joe
scarborough say what did barack obama
say we want to regulate misinformation
and what that means is we want to
regulate things that go against what we
say now let's
compare and contrast that to what ron
desantis and his administration are
saying we and what elon musk is saying
we want to make sure that these
platforms are not regulating information
that they are not putting their foot on
the levers of power and hiding certain
information we just want an even playing
field again that is a fundamental
difference between being on the left and
on the right there is a use for
government and that use for government
would be doing such things as protecting
your first amendment rights and
gosh darn it i'm a proud floridian
and there's something that you can do
too you know what you can do if you're
living in new york under kathy c word
you could get the hell out of there if
you're living in california and there's
an election today by the way
in california and of course newsome is
going to get reelected uh oop i just
said california let me throw some money
in the jar there we go we'll
we're going to kick a floridian we're
going to kick a leftist floridian out
instead of moving a
sane californian inn
to florida
um but you know what you can do you can
take some power into your own life and
how do i know it because it's exactly
what i did and it's exactly what that
guy over there did and it's exactly what
this guy did and a bunch of people that
are downstairs did we got the hell out
of california a place that was
overreaching and depressing and
ridiculous and crime infested and
everything else and we moved to a free
state that's exactly what you can do
i was on fox news on martha mccallum
shows being guests hosted
by trey yesterday and that's exactly
what i was talking about
until the people of los angeles and
california more broadly decide to start
voting for some other people until that
california decides that it can no longer
be a one-party state then this is going
to keep happening there is going to be
more crime there are going to be lighter
sentences and more chaos on the streets
trey i used to see you all the time at
the fox la affiliate and guess what i
now live in the free state of florida
and this is a perfect example of why
more and more people i mean the real
issue here is that more and more people
will see videos like that they will say
boy the administration the mayor doesn't
have our back the d.a doesn't have our
back there are greener pastures out
there and that's why california lost
something like 300 000 people last year
and they're moving to places like
tennessee texas and florida
the clip that you were seeing uh on the
side over there was uh in los angeles
the d.a is a guy by the name of george
gascon i've mentioned him a couple times
he was the da for seven years in san
francisco destroyed
absolutely destroyed san francisco which
is an absolute dump right now not a safe
place and and so many so many people
have fled that but what happens in
progressive politics you actually get a
promotion so he was the d.a he destroys
san francisco and then of course he
becomes the d.a of los angeles by the
way he was bernie backed and he replaced
the first black female d.a in los
angeles history that bernie was against
now i don't care if someone's black or
female they pretend to but then he had
an old white guy bernie bernie got his
progressive old white guy to replace the
young black female d.a because she
wasn't a complete leftist maniac so the
point is your vote can elect politicians
who protect individual rights such as
that right to freedom of speech
okay that's how you make a difference
and as you may remember
i registered as a republican here in
florida last week and as ron desantis
said in our interview i hope i get the
numbers exactly right maybe you guys can
correct me if i'm missing it but when he
got to office it was something like a
300 000
deficit
republican to democrat in this state in
registered voters
and now it's up 200 that's a 500 000
voter swing towards the republican side
i think he's going to win 65 of the vote
here which is absolutely insane i
actually said that to him backstage it
kind of laughed at me but i really think
it's possible find alternative platforms
move to places uh that are more in line
with your values that's how you'll take
power back to your life that's how the
the nonsense and the endless hysteria
that they're constantly going to try to
ramp up
that's how it'll have less of an effect
on you if you live in a place that is
defended by good people because you've
helped those people get into those
offices and if you move to social media
platforms that are more in line with
your values for example locals
that's how you do a little something
that is our show for today we do have a
cold close for you of course and do we
have some locals comments we do have
locals comments because that's where i
check comments
all right annie howe says i'm so glad
the desantis interview was posted for us
the interview made me smile and gave me
hope for the country yeah it was full of
hope there was not any bigotry there you
know we have all these morons outside i
mean they're just morons what else can
you say about these people screaming
that he's a homophobe screaming that
he's racist that he wants to kill people
and everything then you walk inside the
thing you have a thousand cheering
joyous happy people there was nothing
close to bigotry or homophobia or
anything and that disconnect that
disconnect is what we must show people
because as i said yesterday on the show
you know if if the media was honest and
it obviously is not it's like shouldn't
the new york times have covered an event
where ron desantis speaks with you know
this i guess somewhat popular youtube
guy who happens to be gay wouldn't that
be something interesting that they would
talk about but they don't talk about it
right and it's like they wanna another
version of disinformation is things that
they don't want you to talk about right
so i could relate that back to this
thing right here
right the book has absolutely crushed it
in sales we've absolutely crushed it we
should have been number two on the new
york times bestseller list i don't care
about the new york times and i don't
want their approval i believe that the
proof is in the sales the proof is in
the pudding right but why did they not
put it on it's because they don't want
people to know about contrary views and
if they screw with numbers what else do
you think they screw with kathy d says i
bet when aoc bartended she got
everyone's drink wrong and then blame
them can you try to imagine her mixing a
drink yeah i mean she's just it's not
even that she's an idiot like
she's just she's not a person she's a
construct she's a character she is
getting information from somebody and
then she does her little actress routine
and that's what she does margot says my
sister calls him abomination oh that's
good he's an abomination he really is he
really is i regret voting for the guy i
really do guys if you want to play along
and get videos early and ad free and
come to our meetups and our breakfasts
and see smiling happy people and
communicate with me all day long because
i jump on and i i talk to people every
day
reubenreport.locals.com
and of course if you want to join us for
that miami show let's see that image one
more time with my fancy hip cool
synth wave glasses uh you can join me at
the miami improv on july 14th at 8 p.m
dave rubin.com
events and of course part one of the
interview with ron desantis is up right
now on rumble and on the youtube and the
full things up at locals i've enjoyed
today's show i hope you have as well and
uh here's a little orange man to take
you home
since you're attacking us can you give
us a question since you're no mr
president-elect president-elect since
you are attacking our news organization
now can you give us a chance your
organization you are attacking our news
organization organization can you give
us a chance to ask a question sir sir
can you stay mr president-elect go ahead
and you say ask any questions
president-elect can you give us don't be
attacking us can you give us a question
don't be
question i'm not going to give you can
you speak can you state you are fake
news sir can you stay categorically that
nobody
no mr president-elect that's not
appropriate